SIX TIMES, AND TWO IN THE LEAGUE
THAT PLAYED FEWER HOME GAMES,
1 OUT OF 4 OF THE SIX HERE RAM
PITLICK, AND WITH THE SHOT.
COMES AND IT WILL TAKE IT ALL TE
WAWAOUT TO CENTER, HARTMAN OFF F
THEERE, AND DEFLECTEDD UP
LEFT OFF,
THEY WERE SO GOOD LAST YEAR, WE
TALK ABOUT THE STRONG SHIFT AND
ACROSS, AND DEFLECTS, SPINNING
OUT AND
CENTER ICE.TSR INJURY LAW.
CORNER, ERIKSSON EK LIKE IN THE
PLAY, BUT DROPS IT OFF
HINTZ,
HARTMAN WINS THE DRAW CLEA THE E
HAS
THROUGH, AND BACK TO HARTMAN
AN OLD JUMP FROM THE STARS EARLY
IN BY
THE DALLAS STARS THIS PAST
MINUTE.
IT'S JUST STAINING
GREENWAYAY>> Gigi: MINNESOTA WID
PLAYING SO WELL DEFENSIVELY,
JUST KILLING THE BIG PENALTY,
AND D KAPRIZOV, LEAVING ALEX GOI
>> Gigi: THIS IS>> Anthony: HISD
TO THE CORNER, AND THE WILD ARE
ABLE TO WIDE!
NOW ON>> Gigi: THEY DEFINITELY Y
DIFFERENT LOOKS AND WANTED TO
>> Gigi: SUCH A GORGEOUS GOAL.
THE TANDEM WORKING SO WELL THEY,
TWO ON ONE. VICTOR RASK
HEADING OUT WITH THE CLEARED
2-ON
BLUE LINE, AND DOES NOT USUALLY
SHOOT AND HIT YOU IN THE PAST,
HE IS A GUY WHO
THEY CERTAIN